outside today is day three of the
workshop uh
the focus for today is massively
parallel evaluation
there are lots of questions on how the
discussion round is going to go so let
me kind of start off with a quick
preview of how we're going to run it
last time I checked the Google Docs no
one had suggested any open problems so
uh we will essentially run it similar to
how it was done yesterday uh so we'll
have three speakers I'm going to
introduce so uh there will be a total of
four questions that have come up with
related
uh and two of them are
for lack of a better place more like
homework time problems and two are more
open problems uh the heads up
it should be something for everyone
there will be triangles involved there
will be call centers involved
there will also be
other stuff that everyone
um so uh debate the morning schedule
will have two 40-minute trucks uh
primary from the database
I really have a
I've been a five minute break in between
uh then I believe you have a 15 or 20
minute break and then we're now 45
12 and come back to two and we'll start
off at least
um
the logistics
for once I can say we decided something
not
okay good uh so I'm very happy uh
who are two speakers for this morning uh
Paris is
foreign
stuff without sort of
hello everyone uh uh okay so let's get
started because we have a lot of flights
so I don't know how much we're going to
go through
um so uh here is a talk outline and this
is for both me and ciao
um so we're first going to introduce the
NPC model and then we're going to talk
about a bunch of join algorithms in this
model for different kind of for
different cases and different settings
and
um before I start I want to point you to
this thing which is going to be really
helpful so as I were doing uh slides and
discussion with transform we realized
that we're talking about exactly the
same model and then the parameter was
completely different so I think this
will
um be a helpful guide for how things
connect between the talk now and the
talk we're going to hear later by
transun and we're going to introduce all
of these things in the talks but this is
kind of the you should think about does
the connecting the way to connect to
connect the things we're talking about
the same model the same parameters but
the language and the things we care are
slightly different okay I'll get i'll
get a bit to that as we go through the
talk
okay so
um
so before I I talk about the uh the MVC
model I'm going to have one slide that
is not very theoretical and it's kind of
the more practical motivation of this
and then everything else will be Theory
so uh the MBC model was motivated by the
said nothing architecture which is the
prevalent architecture in large scale
systems and the idea is that you have a
bunch of nodes or machines or servers
call them however you want and they talk
to each other through interconnected
network but they said nothing this means
that they don't share memory they don't
sell disk they can only communicate with
each other through a network okay so
this is the model we want to try to
design algorithms on
and of course there's been a lot of work
on how we can model massive parallelism
starting with a PIRA model uh and then
going to the bulk signals parallel motor
Valiant uh the local model and then as
my producer was introduced there were a
bunch of models that try to
theoretically to theoretically
understand how this map reduce
computation is working so
um
okay so let's give let's get down to
understanding the model so essentially
the uh the way computation works is is
exactly like the bsp model right so we
have our input uh I'm going to use end
here to denote the size of the database
when uh is going to talk about graphs C
is going to use m and n as the
parameters of the input which is the
number of edges and the number of
vertices but here when I talk about the
size I'm just going to talk about the
size as the total size of your
relational tables
yes that would be it right so in this
case if you model your graph as relation
table then your n would be equal to this
end okay
but as you will see this end is very
important when you design algo it's
really setting which is why we
distinguish it okay so you have your
input uh it's your database your
database is uh partitioned somehow
initially you have a number of machines
here I'm going to use p as a number of
machines this is uh this parameter here
typically in the database setting we're
going to assume that this p is much much
more than n this kind of makes sense
right so n is this has your database
could be terabyte gigabytes peace and a
number of machines even if you're Google
you don't have more than I don't know 10
000 machines right or something like
that so maybe you have more uh but so it
is safe to assume that and this is
actually really important
um
it turns out that if
p in our case goes really close to N our
algorithms fail
but this is a setting that they it can
be handled here okay so another kind of
Point uh to remember
so uh uh how does the computation
proceed where we have a bunch of steps
around so in every round there is a
local computation this means that you
can do any computation you want but you
can only look at your local data then
you communicate you can send whatever
data you want to whoever whomever you
want okay then there is some kind of
synchronization step so you wait for
everyone to finish to complete the
computation and communication and then
you start
so this is round one and then you stop
the lower again okay so local
computation communication sync is round
two and so on okay in the end uh what we
want we want our output
so if we are in the relation setting we
have a query our output is a just a
query result to be kind of distributed
across your across your nodes okay so it
doesn't be collecting one node it can be
distributed across of course if you're
doing an aggregate where you have one
value then your one value you know you
want to be one machine but in general
can be distributed and with not even ask
that it is it is only partitioned right
so you could have potentially duplicates
in in multiple messages okay
uh any questions so far please interrupt
at any point if you have any questions
okay
um parameters so and this is kind of
this column so the number of servers
this is kind of how much you scale this
is p uh P for us is is a parameter that
is kind of given okay
so you're given a p and then you design
an algorithm you need to design an album
for this particular P the number of
rounds are typically in every in
everything we're going to do in this
talk uh it will be constant
this may depend on the query but will be
independent of the data so if you fix
your query it will be constant that is
not true in a graph setting where you
may need logarithmic number of rounds or
log log rounds okay uh but for whatever
we're going to say today we need the
cost number one usually one or two or or
maybe I don't know what five or six is a
Max or something like that okay so it's
just a content
um
and then the most important parameter is
what we call Maxine load l
so what is that that is we look through
uh for each machine that the data it has
received okay and we ask that the
maximum data that any server has
received throughout this computation is
bounded by this parameter L another way
to think about it is space for machine
okay so how much space do we have right
so this this is kind of the maximum load
uh and here I want to point out that why
do we care about the maximum load versus
the average load well because the
maximum load the machine that has the
most load is the one that's going to uh
basically tell you how much time you
need right because the computation will
be more expensive without machine so
that's what we want to capture
is there an exponent yeah this is P1
over Delta yeah so that's actually the
next slide it's going to be clear okay
so how do this parameters how do we
think about these parameters well okay
so clearly your load uh is upper Bound
by n because you can always send all
your data in one machine and then do no
parallelism and then you find right so
somehow you know this is kind of the
trivial algorithm and then in the ideal
case your load is n over P this means
that you can do you compute whatever you
want and each machine only handles one
over P of your data okay so that's kind
of the perfect case
um
and yes so if you have like a join you
could have modern and right intermediate
results so you're looking only in terms
of input size or also intermediate
result size well we're going to get to
that so we do both yeah we do both so
we'll have results that have to are
dependent on the output size and we have
results that depend on your main input
size okay so in general what we want to
do if we don't care about the uh the
input size we want to have something a
form that it looks like n over P to the
one over Delta and this Delta goes
between zero and one okay so uh you can
you can you can always you can you can
always see that there exists such a
Delta that's a constant to do that uh
because in the worst case you can
basically send everything to one machine
right so so we would be interested in
this including this as well
question is and particular what we care
in the database world is suppose I give
you a number of rounds maybe it's
constant and then a number of machines
and an input how what is the best load
you can you can do for that particular
uh for that particular query okay and
then we want to do uh something like in
the sequential setting where we want to
say for this query you have this load uh
similarly for this query you can do this
random
okay
two examples that are going to make this
very concrete
you can think about it as very simple
why n over p is best or you are asking
the question the minimum the minimum
load yeah yes
well your communication cost is actually
uh determined by your load right because
if you know that its machine has L then
your communication is at most P times P
times l
sorry
you could yeah that's a rough upper
Bound in other cases it is exactly that
because we're doing symmetric things but
you could have you could have potential
less yes yes
well every machine is all things so the
total communication is p times l
it's very proficiently yes
you could have so so this thing this
total communication can be more than n
in most cases will be more than n which
means you're going to duplicate if you
think about ideally you want to send its
item once right you will you will do
have some replication
uh let's do two examples and things will
become yes
it's known as a local computation as you
said yeah
but it can use auxiliary space that is
not part of the load or it cannot it can
use whatever space it wants that's not
part of the load so the the load only
governs how much data it receives yes
you can use and use the exponential yeah
we don't care we don't bound that yeah
that's a good question though
okay okay
example first we want to compute the
intersection of two relations of size n
okay
so how do we do that well this is kind
of like a Zone but it's a very easy case
of a join so what you would do you could
do uh what we call a hash join so you'd
have a hash function uh well assume that
it this is a unit a function that
uniformly Maps the elements from your
domain to one of your servers uniformly
at random
uh and then whenever you have a tuple
from R from the form array you're going
to plug the value a in the hash function
do the same machine
same for S and then you can see that if
you do the local computation it works
because if you have two elements that
intersect they will be mapped to the
same machine so it will be correct if
you don't intersect you don't care where
they are right so this is a correct
algorithm and then this works in one
round the communicate it once and then
uh you can see that the load will be on
the order of n byp okay because here
again this only works if n is greater
than p uh much much greater than MP but
essentially in that case your your load
will be uniformly distributed
um and then you will get an optimal load
yes do you have any specifications as to
where the output needs to be no
so you could you just leave it
distributed and yeah yeah all right
right that's yeah we want our output to
just be distributed and don't care where
exactly it is I mean of course that's
good for compositionality yeah
yes
it's just worth learning and then I'll
shut up about this premise but
um this requires a round of
communication but it doesn't actually
require synchronization yes
yes and I I was I was going to get to
that but all of our algorithms don't
require synchronization because we are
doing monotone computations okay so uh
uh I will I will I will get to that uh
in
but so far all our the algorithms we're
going to say at least for uh
the next hour or so are going to be it
for the first part are going to be one
round algorithms right so in one round
you don't need any
okay uh yeah that's the computation okay
any questions about that is this clear
so here we get an optimal kind of an
optimal algorithm right because our load
is n over p uh we have one round you
know best case scenario
okay
uh now let's do something a little a
little bit more tricky uh now we want to
compute the Cartesian product of two
relations okay so they have suppose they
have the same size and we want to
compute our pair so in our output we
want one pair to be in in summer scene
right
uh so how do we do that
well one way to do that would be to
basically send to broadcast one of your
relations to all the machines and then
partition the other has partition the
other relation but then your load would
be n plus n over P so it would be order
of n okay which is kind of bad
so the question is can we do better than
that and the answer is yes so here's the
idea I'm going to take my P machines and
organize them in a square
uh
in if my sizes are equal of the two
relations I want to compute the
Cartesian product this uh this actually
will be a square so it says it will be
square root of P if the size were not
equal it would be a rectangle where you
want the larger size to be on your
larger relation okay
so here and then I just map one of the
so it's one of these queries is one
machine right so this must be one two
square root of P Square to P plus one
and so on
so now what we're going to do is that
um
you're still going to have a hash
function this has function will now map
to uh one to square root of P so you can
think it will map either to one row
uniformly and random or one column
uniformly at random
so if you have a tuple of the form R A
that comes from R you can do your hash
function will pick a random row and then
it's going to send it to all the
machines in that row
and symmetrically for S it's going to
pick at random one column using the hash
function and set it to all the machines
in this column okay so now you can see
that we are doing some replication right
because it's data item is sent is
replicated square root of three times
okay so now your total communication
will be square root of P times n okay
whereas before here your total
communication was uh just n
okay so why why is this correct well
here the argument is kind of pictorially
uh
you can see it here well if you have a
pair A and B then the pair will be both
values will be in the intersect of your
o and your code right so every row and
every column will always intersect in
one machine that must equal
so if you do after you send if you do
local computation we're going to
correctly compute all your pairs
now what is your load well you can make
a similar argument as before but now
you're not uh sending you you know you
have this replication so it's machine
will receive n by P a x plus n by P Y
and then this is 2N over square root of
three okay and if even if you didn't
have this you could basically calculate
we're going to see how you can calculate
the optimal dimensions of your
okay so here your load is of the form n
by P to the one half so it's not as good
as n by P that we want it but it's
better than n okay we can actually show
this is optimal so you cannot do better
than that
questions
can just like in one more what's the
technique you use to show this aftermath
like it's the information oh no it's
actually Counting because so this is an
important point we're not going to talk
about lower bounds that much but uh we
just say the total output is N squared
and this output must be among these
machines if each machine receives L data
it can produce L squared things so P
times L squared is something like that
yeah so it's just accounting argument
super
simple videos
yeah you choose one row uh and one
column randomly yeah
that's where you need our functions
I think the question was what if you did
you just deterministically yeah uh Xiao
is going to talk a little bit about
deterministical so you can Implement all
of these algorithms in the domestic
fashion as well it's just the
yeah we can discuss what is what is
easier I think for database purposes you
want to do this type of thing in
practice theoretically sometimes it's
easier to to argue about deterministic
algorithms but there you need to we do
need to sort to do this kind of things
there was a question uh
there's an analogy to Quorum systems
there's bridge quorums look exactly like
this and the idea that any two parts
overlap is pretty similar to keeping the
cross product I don't know if this is
something you guys have explored but it
might be fine I think it's pretty it's
pretty stuff also
okay yes
right no so here no synchronization is
needed to make sure that you use the
same functions oh yes yes yes uh yes
right this has function uh will
yes they have to use the same as
function okay and this is free wait I
don't think in this case maybe it's not
important but in the in intersection it
is really important yeah use the same
function I could I wouldn't call that
synchronization it's sort of like a bad
reviews use we do not say that it's a
difference between compilation phase
versus execution based so presumably
that hash function is installed
yeah I mean in practice you wouldn't use
a a function that guarantees uniformly
at random things right you will do
something that has a weaker guarantee
theoretically you're going to get the
same guarantee in practice you know it
would be okay
yeah so in the in in the deterministic
setting you can actually instead of
doing hashing you're going to do sorting
and the sorting by sorting things they
say this is uh like we have the
house-based algorithm the sword-based
algorithm
so the surveys will give you
deterministic algorithm the trade-off is
that you need more rounds
so so here we need one round and it's
done when you do something you have to
do one more with constant number so you
have to pay across the number of rounds
because you have to collect some
statistics
okay great questions
uh great so uh okay so now let's try to
think about General joints uh and we're
first going to talk about the skew free
case which is the easier thing to think
about uh and we have the kind of
cleanest results and then I'm going to
talk a little bit about worst case
optimality uh if if I have time for that
okay so
um
how do we think about skew well let's
think about something that has
absolutely no skew whatever so what I
mean by that
so uh let's look at this type of the
database
so you have a relation relation contains
exactly in doubles and then basically
every attribute contains its value once
right so when I say I have no skill this
means that if you look at the frequency
of its value at every column is exactly
one every value appears exactly one
right so if you think about your
relation as a bipartite graph then this
bipartite graph is a matching okay
and if it was in if it was a tenant
relation then it would look
okay so
um think about this object for uh for
for this time and then I'm going to uh
to talk a bit about okay how uh what
happens if we don't have this very nice
service so Paris yes
how normal do you want that no skill
definition to be I will I will get into
that so for now for now assume that we
have this type of database and we're
going to do our algorithm here and then
I'm going to relax it a bit
okay okay so right now we have just this
table where every attribute is a key yes
essentially don't kill but this is not
that we should remember
right so this has no skew by some
definition of skew which I'm going to
get to that okay
um
but yeah our notion of skew is very uh
ill-defined I have to say so uh I will I
will get this is actually one of the
exercises in later this afternoon okay
so uh let's do our favorite query
triangles okay
so
now what we want to do is we want to
compute the triangles
okay but our relations are of this form
okay
so every ball basically appears once
so how do we do that well I have to say
we want to do that in one round okay if
you have two rounds then it's very easy
you would basically take out an S you
would run your kind of same intersection
thing you could get an intermediate
relation this intermediate relation
would have still size or when because
you have no everybody appears once right
so that their media size doesn't blow up
this is very important and then you
would take this and do another
intersection with t and then you would
compute your triangles but you need two
rounds okay so the question is can you
do it in one round
and the answer is yes but of course you
can't you know achieve uh the optimal uh
NFP that you want you achieve something
else so what's the idea where the ideas
you will generalize this idea of the
square to more Dimensions right and how
do we think about that well our
Dimensions is essentially the number of
variables you have uh in particular it's
not the number of variables you can just
look at the number of joint variables
you have so here we have three Zone
variables so this means that I will
basically have a three-dimensional space
this means I will map my machines to a
three-dimens to a three-dimensional Cube
right so I can think about one dimension
the cube as variable X the other y the
other Z here uh just assuming that all
the relations are the same the size of
its Dimension will be the cubic root of
P okay
um and then what do I do well
what let's suppose I want to see where
I'm going to say this Tuple are of a b
well the idea here is that in this table
of Arab I have a fixed value of uh I
know my value of x I know my value y but
my number by value of Z which is the
third dimension is unknown so I've got
to pass on the dimensions I know and
replicate on the dimension I don't know
how does this look geometrically
geometrically this looks like I pick a
random point in the square and then I
send it to all the to the column here
okay
so this could be uh uh yeah so you would
send it to the point where you apply a
hash function on a has function of B and
then here this means you replicate right
so you save it all cubic root of pmas
instead of here
and then you do it for the other
dimensions symmetrically why is this a
correct algorithm well suppose you have
a triangle then you can see that all the
tuples that you need for this triangle
would appear in this intersection of
these three
three lines okay so this middle one has
all the doubles you want so if you say
and then you do a local computation on
the local data you receive you've
correctly computed all the triangles
okay
uh what is the load well you can see
that essentially you're replicating it's
thing it could be cubic root of times so
your load will be n by P to the third
right and here I should say that in
order to get this load that's where you
need the assumption that you have its
value appears once because if it doesn't
appear once then you uh you actually
cannot guarantee that this will be your
load cannot kind of the uniform
distribution
okay any questions about this algorithm
okay
uh now you can just generalize this idea
so you take the your P machines you're
organizing the hypercube the dimensions
of the hypercube are the number of
variables you have in your query and
then here I'm not even assuming that
every relation has the same size so you
can take your relations to be of
different size and then if you want to
say to see what you're going to say the
etapo then essentially what you're doing
is you you're looking at the variables
in this relation you're passing these
variables and then you're replicating in
the variables that are not inside
okay
uh so you yeah you're broadcasting along
basically along the missing Dimension
that you passing along the dimensions
you know and then after you do you send
this again this is a one round algorithm
you do a local computation and again
using the same argument you can
guarantee if there is an answer then
basically uh you have uh if there is an
output Apple you have all the necessary
data to generate it in your uh in some
node okay
great so uh
let's so that's good so now let's do
some analysis okay
yes
uh no here we want the full yeah the
full result yeah no projections
okay so let's do some analysis well uh
how first of all the product yes
you will uh yes I'll get to that in this
slide okay
so the first one is that of course the
total the product of the shares is p
right because your your hypercube needs
to basically be all your machines so you
need to choose yourself so that your you
can use less if you want so it's less or
equal to p
and then here is where you use the
matching databases the matching thing so
how many how do we compute the load in
this case so how many tuples will
machine receive from this relation is J
okay
so the idea is that
um
well this is the number the number of
tuples you have from uh from this
relation and then because you're
partitioning on on all of these then
you're going to receive this divided by
uh by the product of the sales okay
so now why why do we need uh why do we
need matching database to guarantee that
well essentially uh in a matching
database
you have
because its value appear once it means
you have some kind of independence of
where things are sent
if you have if your values appear more
than once you're introducing
correlations so you cannot guarantee
that things will be uniformly
distributed
so then this means that this actually
and again this is here we're using a
randomized algorithm right so this is
approximately or with high probability
that that will not be true anymore okay
that's good so so this is how many
things you receive and then what is the
load well you're receiving this from
every database so you need to basically
take the marks of that and then you want
to minimize this is your load so this is
the quantity you want to minimize
okay
so it turns out that we can
equivalently we can show that we can
compute equivalently using this this
dual program so you can you can take
this is essential optimization problem
you can turn it into a linear problem uh
which is some kind of dual of that and
here this uh we won't go to the details
of that but here uh this EI I'm
basically writing the series P to the e
i that's I'm basically taking uh the
logarithms of that so here we have an LP
and then you can see that the only
parameters of urlp is your the structure
of your query and this has your
relations you plug in these values and
then you can compute the optimal sales
that will give you uh the optimal
um not the optimal they will give you
the optimal uh size of the of the
hypercube
okay questions
I I will not go into how we generate
that but I just wanted to the takeaway
Point here is that there is a a way to
to compute exactly the shares that you
want to have you know yes it's all
integers right so couldn't you just try
the prime factorization like just kind
of like you know create FP you look at
all the possible factors
and then look at their combinations yeah
so here uh this is a very good point so
here I'm basically assuming that P is
large enough so uh I can I can basically
don't need to care if they're integers
or not and it gets us around and have no
problems of course if your p is like 80
then you do have this kind of problems
people try like let's see if it's a
prime number you would try smaller
numbers just kind of effective yeah so
Dan had a paper where they
uh with sumo where you read this this
type of things because in reality if you
have like uh some number then it's it's
unclear you can do this with integers
right so
um you can do a bunch of tricks to go
around that but theoretically imagine
that P is large enough so we don't care
about that
yes
sort of like a generalized version of
communication avoid English culture
communication of communication avoiding
measures multiplying algorithms
because they're those very similar
analysis I think
yeah
uh Matrix application is a very special
type of job
with the matching database yeah so
right so I actually had an example so in
reality we
um
so this is kind of the upper bound
theorem is that uh the result we get
does not only hold formatting databases
but for any database where the frequency
of its value is at most n over B
so so I I just did Imagine episode we
can think easier but really you can
relax that and still have an algorithm
that that works this load
yeah so you got your thread so much
database your skew threshold is one but
in reality it can be in practice can be
much much bigger
so
so here uh
it turns out you can have a closed form
solution of this
yes
so the so the optimal load you can also
uh think about is equivalent to
maximizing this expression okay so now
what do we have here so here I'm taking
that's the product of the relation
raised to this UJ divided by P to the
one over the sum of the uj's and here
the this weights must form a fragile
Edge packing of the hypergraph of the
query so what's the fraction let's
packing well I want to assign a weight
to its hyper Edge so to its atom of my
query such as for each variable the sum
of the edges that that include this
variable is at most one okay
so for the triangle we could put half
half and half
right so here you can see that in every
variable it's going to have exactly
exactly one okay so and then what we're
interested in is uh so if it let's take
these to be equal all of them to be
equal to n just to make it easier then
this disappears and this becomes this
expression so now what if we want to
find kind of the optimal the optimal
algorithm we want to minimize this
quantity so we want to find a fraction
let's parting such that the total sum of
the weight is as small as possible yes
for each variable sum of edges is at
least one right
you pack yeah so this is not a net cover
this is not the fraction it's covered
it's a fraction it's packing
okay when we do the AGM bound we talk
about the function let's cover where you
want to to guarantee that the sum of it
is at least one here we pack so it has
to be at most one find the minimum size
why can't I just put everything to zero
uh that's a good question so this is
probably the maximum size
so here you want to maximize and the
reason you want to maximize is because
this does not give you an algorithm this
gives you a proof that you cannot do any
better so the the more you maximize the
closer you'll get to what you might be
actually yeah this is this is wrong this
is the maximum size okay yeah okay
yeah so in the edge cover you want to
minimize the expect you want to maximize
yeah thank you
all right yes
in some cases to arrange the servers not
in a height or cubic function but
I don't know
let's say you don't have uh you know
cardinality and friends but the
ingredients ones in general
uh would it make sense to have other
Arrangement configuration
yeah so so uh this algorithm Works only
for one round skew three if you want to
do other things you have to do more
complicated things like partition your
data and then do the other types of
things so this hyper keeps structure
this this type of algorithm is very
simple but is optimal only for very
specific cases a one round skew free
otherwise it doesn't work and you have
to do you have partitioned your data
first according heavy light and I do
different different things for different
type of Provisions I don't know if
that's a different hypercube but
one way to think is you have different
hypercubes that deal with different
different data
thank you
foreign
I think we're out but I want to finish
this part at least and then
if that's yeah I think so I have a good
stopping point okay so uh okay so this
means that you can think about the
optimal load we get from this algorithm
as this expression and now we can start
thinking about different sparkings right
so let's again look at the triangle
let's suppose we have the half half it's
parking that gives you this load okay
notice that if all our relations are the
same size you get n over P to the two
thirds but again this is here I also
deal with relations have different sizes
also one zero zero is also a valid
that's parking this will give you this
load and symmetrical get this and this
okay
so your load in the end is going to be
the maximum of all this expression you
can actually show that these are kind of
your external points of your polytop so
you don't any other it's parting of the
put is going to be dominated by one of
these
okay
so uh so now how do we think about this
right so this clear this just
corresponds to the hypercube algorithm
where we have
um
right but what about this case like what
what does this correspond to an
algorithm so here here is what happens
right remember that these sizes now are
not equal okay so here this is the case
where this relation R is much much
bigger than T and S
in this case your optimal algorithm is
not to do the hypercube well you do the
hypercube but the hybrid corresponds to
broadcasting T you broadcast s and then
you just partition our uh among your
machines so you're going to
your your load is going to be the size
of r divided by P but then T and S are
so much smaller that they don't even
affect your load okay
so uh and this of course corresponds to
an appropriate Serial Set allocation to
your to your dimensions
great so uh so this is I have like two
slides and then I'll stop
so this is kind of the upper bound so
you can show that the hypercube
algorithm computes any conjunctive query
and its own query with one round and
load given by n over P to the one
divided by this optimal uh functional
it's packing number
and this is a randomized algorithm so it
has an exponentially small probability
of failure but hereby probability of
failure I mean I don't mean that the
algorithm is not going to be correct I
mean that your load is going to exceed
this load
and then your input is sq3 database so
what I mean by that
is uh
uh that the frequency of its value is at
most n over P okay yes why is it
randomized it's just because of pressure
yeah so the correctness is is always
correct the randomization is on the on
the load you get so this load is with
high probability
uh well think about it on the order you
you know not exact but but you can yeah
you can also do that as a uh
okay uh right so
and we can actually show that there is
actually if we restrict the one round
algorithms this is a type result so
if you want to design any one round
algorithm that computes the query then
you need this load and actually the
lower bound user needs to matching
database so a matching database suffice
is to to get you to to this load okay
so uh
just to summarize what this tells us is
that if we are in one round and you have
no skew as defined in this case then we
know the optimal algorithm okay and now
of course what we ask is okay what
happens if you have skew and what
happens if you have multiple rounds okay
so this is what we're going to do after
a break
the input matching database what is the
intuition that you get a lower bound
because you need to reasonable all
possible algorithms or something
how do you how do you what is the idea
of this okay lower bound
um so you just reason about the beats
that you get so so you have to reason
now but if if you want to allow your log
to do anything you can send beats that
combine different things right so what
you argue is that the number of bits you
receive from each relation does not
suffice to locally generate all the
results that you need
okay so every machine every machine
after one round of communication will
receive some Beats
from every relation
and it turns out that if you uh if you
put a bound then you cannot you can
retrieve only some type of from these
bits you can retrieve only some tuples
from this relation and the establish
will not be enough to construct all the
possible outputs that you want I said
you start from the output size and
Reason by quotes that you need to do
yeah yeah this is so that's that's a uh
that's what the question before it's a
counting argument
information Theory so accounting is not
enough you really need to yeah some
information Theory and Counting yeah
but it doesn't say anything about uh it
doesn't have to do with communication
complexity arguments though
well importantly because you say it's
one round so yes
yeah well I'm going to talk about yeah
yeah yeah yeah but yes this is a one
round algorithm yeah that's very
important
all right so let's take a quick
five minute break uh let's come back
chocolate